today we're going to be canceling with
great wrath and vengeance reverend bob
mccabe a pastor at the church of the
divine child catholic church michigan
um reverend bob is is canceled for being
yet another spineless gutless skinless
nearly translucent
jellyfish-like creature masquerading as
a leader and shepherd of christ's flock
specifically reverend bob is canceled
for apologizing for a good
truthful and necessary homily given by
his associate pastor
father paul graney at the 430 mass this
past saturday
apparently caused controversy by
speaking plainly and honestly
about antifa and blm here's a bit of
what
father granny said well these days if
you turn on the news or
open a newspaper or click on any news
source online the past
three four months or so you've seen
maybe some of the ugliest times in our
nation's
history people have been out in our
streets doing incredibly violent things
in the name of justice
cars have been torched property has been
destroyed
businesses looted and burned and police
officers
and other people have been intimidated
assaulted
and even murdered all in the name of
justice
oftentimes rallying cry being no justice
no peace well this past week just a
couple days ago
i think yesterday marked the 19th
anniversary of 9 11 when islamic
terrorists hijacked
passenger airplanes and flew them into
the world
trade center in new york city now father
granny went on to say that
al qaeda came with the goal to destroy
america little by little with acts of
terror but in 2020 many of our own
people are now
out there in the streets wanting to
remake america into something else by
destroying what it is today
little by little there's no great army
but it's a riot but it's riot by riot
now reading from the detroit news
article on this has a little bit more
information it says uh grainy singled
out two groups he said intended to quote
implement communism a stateless
classical society one was antifa
and then the other was black lives
matter the associate pastor called the
first an anarchist terrorist
organization
and rejected the second as working
against the traditional family structure
and he read aloud from the blm website
from the pulpit
this is great um al qaeda's goal was to
come to the united states and kill
americans
really just wanted to wipe america off
the map quoting now from from father
granny
and they they would have done it if they
could but today those who
we see wanting to bring down america are
americans and they want to do it under
the facade of justice freedom and love
but it's all a bunch of baloney it's
anti-christian
it's anti-family it's evil that was the
humbling
everything you said there of course
entirely absolutely
undeniably true not just true it's a
necessary truth
that many christians in the pews need to
hear how do i know they need to hear it
well precisely because so many of them
apparently didn't want to hear it
they complained and cried and they said
that the mean priests made their tummies
hurt
and that's when reverend bob stepped in
and uh he
uh admonished the the the priest
publicly in a statement on facebook he
posted he said
uh i am so sorry that a homily given by
father paul granny at the 4 30 p.m mass
on saturday was has brought forth
division anger confusion and chaos
chaos there's chaos in the streets
because of this homily that a priest
gave in the 4 30 p.m mass in michigan
uh he said i spoke first with a couple
individuals shortly after this homily i
could sense their anger and their hurt
anger and hurt at what it's true
reverend bob
were they angry and hurt because the
truth that father granny shared was
difficult
to hear were they angry and hurt because
the truth was politically inconvenient
to them and they don't want others to
find out about it
were they angry and hurt because well
you know what it doesn't matter
if you're angry and hurt by simply by
simple statements of truth
that's on you that's your problem
um it goes on here this is the more of
the statement mccabe said he
he spoke with granny quote to express my
opinion that his homily was not pastoral
or sensitive to all the people who would
be hearing it
i also expressed concern that he did not
attend did not mention any of the
scriptures proclaimed at mass
a homily is supposed to reflect on and
break open the word of god proclaimed
the next day grainy gave a pastorally
sound uh homily based on the scriptures
mccabe said
he went on to say as your pastor i want
to assure you that at divine child we
love and respect all persons
every person is sacred in the eyes of
god regardless of their race religion or
sexuality
at different times we need to focus on
our different groups and their
particular needs right now
the murder of countless persons of color
demands a clear response the entire
human family needs to unite in
confronting these injustices
we must protect the lives of persons of
color and be the voice for people who do
not have one
okay let me just say a few things here
first of all i can guarantee
you that this is the first time old bob
has ever had a problem with a priest
not citing the gospel during his homily
i tell you that right now
his concern here has nothing to do with
the priest's failure to break open the
word of god
as it happens one of the one of the
readings at mass last weekend
was sir act 27 30 which says quote
resentment and anger these are foul
things too and a sinner is a master at
them both whoever exacts vengeance will
experience the vengeance of the
lord who keeps strict account of sin
elm is all about exacting vengeance for
perceived offenses committed against
them
it's all about resentment and anger
that's the entire movement
those are its guiding principles would
reverend bob have been okay with the
homily had father granny made this
explicit connection something tells me
he wouldn't have been
second the message delivered from the
pulpit
should not be sensitive to those who who
hear it if by sensitive you mean
concerned primarily with protecting
their fragile feelings
that is not what the priest is there to
do that's not why the church exists
that's not why people walk through those
doors and if that is why they walk
through the doors to have their ears
tickled and their feelings
protected then it's better to scare them
straight slap some sense into them
rather than sacrifice truth for their
sake
third no in fact we do not need to hear
homilies about how the murder of persons
of color is bad
we don't need to hear the priest stand
up there and tell us that it's wrong for
racist white people to murder black
people
everybody knows that everyone agrees
with that everyone in the church already
fully and totally and completely
understands that they don't need to be
told
there's nothing more to be said on the
subject also it just so happens there is
no such epidemic as i've covered many
times those those kinds of murders are
extremely extremely extremely rare
and none of the high-profile police
killings in recent years have had any
established or even plausible link to
racism but aside from that
sermons against racism sermons against
white supremacists killing black people
sermons about the wonders of racial
unity
these are useless messages for the
reason that everybody already agrees
it's the same reason why i assume and i
would hope a priest isn't going to get
up there on the anniversary of d-day
and deliver a message explaining why the
nazis were bad
there was a time and place where such a
message was needed and real courage was
required to give it
bonhoeffer is a good example but that
time and place
is not here thankfully so what a priest
should be doing is thinking to himself
what can i say to these people that they
might not already
know or might not fully understand what
is it that they actually need to hear
the only reason he should ask himself
what the congregation wants to hear is
just so he can rule those subjects out
completely
people can go anywhere to hear what they
want to hear much of the media in
hollywood and pop culture exists
precisely to scratch that itch the
church should not be
in the giving them what they want to
hear business
it should be in the truth business the
hard truth business
the necessary truth business in fact if
you're a priest
and you give a homily and it doesn't
upset anybody in the pews
then it was probably a waste of time but
that's what the priest here did
he upset some people he spoke some truth
and of course the feckless coward
masquerading as a spiritual leader
apologize for
it and for that he is
canceled but we should all we should all
uh
speaking of supporting people who
support us we should all support
christian leaders
priests pastors who actually do like
this priest who get up there and speak
um truth because here's the other thing
they're gonna they're gonna have to deal
as we saw here they're gonna have to
deal with the wrath
from many of the cowards in the pews and
also
the cowards who are above them that's
what we saw here so
that priest is canceled the other priest
is uh is the opposite of canceled
whatever that is
we'll just we'll give him a round of
applause hey you uh
yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated